14h hôpital de l'ouest parisien attrape
le docteur christian couturier a revêtu
sa tenue
direction le bloc opératoire du centre
sos mains créée en 2003 cette structure
est spécialisé dans la chirurgie
orthopédique de la main au programme
huit opérations première patiente un
poignet douloureux à cause de son
cubitus
moi je suis un peu maniaque j'aime bien
que ma tablette soit bien rangé quand
c'est le bazar dessus je râle
l'intervention dure 45 minutes 6 aux
pinces si tous ces outils sont
miniaturisés pour apporter de la
précision aux praticiens avec en
complément des instruments
technologiques
voilà objectif atteint maintenant on
ferme parce que c'est toujours mieux de
refermer des patients à la fin d'une
opération sinon ça fait pas infinies
co-créateur du centre sos mains
christian couturier enchaîne les
pratiques chirurgicales la structure est
composée de huit chirurgiens et de
jeunes praticiens en remplacement auprès
du docteur couturier ils viennent
compléter leur formation
je trouve que c'est un excellent
chirurgien et puis là un avantage en
plus et il est très pédagogue
je dirais que docteur couturier exigeant
pointilleux méticuleux eux et parfois
trail avec lui quand il n'opère pas le
docteur couturier fait des consultations
à la clinique de l'olivier de montigny
le bretonneux sa vocation chirurgicale
est né dans sa jeunesse durant ses
vacances en vendée il passait du temps
avec un vétérinaire et le cubitus
je voulais être vétérinaire
malheureusement je n'étais pas un élève
assidu et j'avais pas très très bon
dossier
ce qui fait que le bac en poche je me
suis retrouvé avec l'impossibilité de
rentrer dans les écoles vétérinaires et
en fait j'ai adoré médecine dès le
premier cours je me suis dit c'est ça
que je veux faire
l'étudiant couturier fait ses études de
médecine à nantes reçus au concours de
l'internât à paris pour devenir
spécialiste
son choix s'est porté sur la main c'est
une spécialité extrêmement variés
hiadlovsky a du nerf il ya de l'artère
il ya des tendons il ya du mou de la
superficie de la profondeur c'est d'une
richesse incroyable
ces cinq années d'internât se déroule au
centre universitaire sos mains de
l'hôpital bichat sous les ordres du
professeur alnot un chirurgien habitué
aux internes expérimenté il avait
interdit au jeune christian couturier
d'opérer un jour la proviseure masmejan
me tenait les écarteurs et je prenais le
bistouri pour la première fois et je
viens 6 le patient est alors évidemment
juste à ce moment là le professeur alnot
rentrer dans la salle il y avait un
brouhaha vent et tout d'un coup plus un
bruit et moi qui c'est tout frais émoulu
je connaissais pas les règles donc je
continue d'opérer je discute avec
professeurs masmejan et là j'entends le
souffle lourds du patron dans mon cou
qui me crie couturier mais qu'est ce que
tu fais jeudi mais monsieur jeu j'opère
en 2001 il est nommé chirurgien une
opportunité se présente à lui la
possibilité de s'installer à trappes en
2003 le 24 janvier 2017 christian
couturier fêtera ses 50 ans
collaboration internationale travaux de
recherche christian couturier poursuit
plusieurs projets avec en tête ce
leitmotiv qu'il aime répéter à ses
enfants disait la lune parce que si vous
échouez vous finirez quand même parmi
les étoiles